herzlich willkommen zu den neuen blog es
sind gerade tatsächlich 18 gerade in
köln ist es am besten ist es nicht so
schönes wetter aber sein 34
hey und moritz albers in köln weil wir
wieder folgen für unseren podcast auf
dem werden dick und doof bleibt doof
bewusst podcast zu hören gibt deswegen
ist aber auf jeden fall hier in köln und
moritz ist hier in köln weil wir
eigentlich noch feiern waren allerdings
passiert heute tatsächlich noch etwas
krasses in diesem blog und zwar
eigentlich wollen wir das ganze schon
vor einer woche drehen da habe ich auch
schon ein bisschen gebraucht aber
irgendwie war ich damit dem locken
zufrieden aber dennoch hier ein paar
ausschnitte von dem blog den ich vor
einer woche aufgenommen habe aber noch
nicht hochgeladen habe aber noch die
ausschnitt und die clips so viel spaß
dabei
[Musik]
heiliger aber seither ständig habe ich
ans netz gebracht
die leute sagen wir es auf jeden fall
heute in köln weil wir weitere fünf
unseren podcast aufnehmen
jeden donnerstag 18 uhr wollen auch
erstmal ganz ganz kurz bedanken für
riesiges feedback hat auch 3d
musikcharts 21 lieder krank muss aber
voll viele andere youtuber stehen das
wir feiern also danke für euer board
oder jeden donnerstag 18 uhr dick und
doof
also ich jetzt gerade der flop kommt am
donnerstag macht gerade online gegangen
freuen
wir fahren jetzt allerdings erst mal zu
mir
wolle die kontrolle die content bahn
heutigen video auf jeden fall noch
passieren wir gäste das reduziert das
unternehmen das so ziemlich die
krassesten in die höhlen aller zeiten
mal hier habe ich tatsächlich angefragt
ob ich alles schon wieder ich habe vor
ein paar monaten mal auf klassenfahrt
reagiert und die hatten dort eine
rheinische korb und gemeinde recke ist
mir aufgefallen ist nicht selbst auch
eine reine schilder habe renault zielt
die leute von heute gesehen was ich
gedacht jetzt ziemlich besoffene
kooperation und ich so klares heftiger
also ich stehe voll hinter dem
unternehmer nicht fertig übertrieben
werden deswegen haben die mir jetzt
tatsächlich keine höhlen zugeschickt mit
von protector und beck protector und
hülle und kameralinsen teilhaben lassen
das handy sagt hallo wir werden auf
jeden fall haben sich was mit dem handy
machen wir werden das umwerfen wir
werden vermutlich auch noch mit dem auto
drüber fahren also es wird auf jeden
fall spannend aber wir gehen erst mal
gleich etwas essen
oh nein oh mein gott nein
tropfen neue im alter betroffen ist
direkt auf die kamera gefallen
vielleicht habe das sogar gehört jetzt
auf jeden fall alle bürger ist sandra
die sonneberger land angekommen und hier
gibt es einfach so keine ahnung für
kinder so ein bisschen mal stifte und
papier und dann darauf zu schreiben
erzählt die andere alles heck 420 und
von einzigen geholt damit nicht wenn du
nicht triffst dich nicht rein alles gut
kommt nicht mehr ran
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt erst mal ein handy fallen
hast du meinen boden und willst du
zuerst einfach mal hinschmeißen also
hast das natürlich mit sie nicht zu
hause
ich sollte jetzt nicht die hülle kaufen
und dann im auto drüber fahren weil mit
panzern haben was das ist natürlich
nicht da man sollte da eigentlich machen
jetzt wirklich kompletten crash
[Gelächter]
du kannst viel darüber erfahren wir
freuen uns ist eine brotzeit ist
nochmals so hoch wie du kannst also das
sind dann locker mehr als zwei meter wir
müssen einen schritt weiter gehen als um
ein gott war das laut du hast willst du
mich verarschen die machen jetzt
challenge mit dem papier kränker er
unserem basketballkorb und zwar stehen
hier vorne hin also bei mir vor das
schuhregal und wir stellen uns nun hier
vorne hin hinter den korb unter dem
hintern in die säule und müssen das ding
treffen mit dem handy also netto
[Musik]
was der betroffene gar keine zeit hat es
nichts drum jungen war es ist nichts
dran halten
es ist halt
wo fragt das ist voll gegen die wand um
ein gut es geht noch es ist nichts
passiert es ist nichts passiert hier ist
ein bisschen drauf aber es ist nichts
passiert hier soll ein schritt weiter
und zwar mit bisher bis ende januar auf
mein holzparkett hier geschmissen und
kurz mal gegen die wand ist es durch
geflogen und im papierkorb eingefahren
jetzt allerdings zu moritz k o wir
bringen moore ist jetzt auf jeden fall
zu seinem auto zurück nach dortmund
fährt und dann werden wir dort das handy
auch nochmal auf asphaltierten straße
schmeißen
ich hoffe dass das ding das über den
luchs nach hinten den rückspiegel und
ich sind jetzt angekommen an dem
parkplatz wo es gepackt hat und hier ist
die straße als ein bisschen uneben
asphaltiert aber wir werden jetzt hier
erst mal das handy aus sandras höhe
fallen lassen und wir haben schon mehr
chips als beim parkett
das funktioniert das dings gekommen das
funktioniert auch das ist ja das ging
die hülle ist halt auch noch relativ
heirat moritz es 188 und lässt das handy
unserem kopf auf dem boden fallen
es ist immer noch ein also es ist etwas
anders
sf komplett also klar dass sie ist es
natürlich gespannt was das video ist
wird er selbstverständlich aber ich
meine wir lassen uns fallen und nicht
die menschen
es funktioniert perfekt jetzt machen wir
den ultimativen test freunde und zwar
packen wir das handy was noch komplett
hier
moritz carol oates werte einfach drüber
mit seinem auto ich mache jetzt auch
noch ganz krass und zwar lege ich das
glas nach unten also
komm doch mal rüber nach vorne
es ist einfach heiler wir packen jetzt
noch mal die scheibe also den stream vom
handy nach oben und schauen ob da auch
noch mal was passieren wird
nein das funktioniert die bildschirm
lopesan aber alter es funktioniert der
geist es geht wenn das ding jetzt auch
andere aushält alter dann ist ja normal
ich bringe mal drauf einmal und jetzt
schmeißt aber auf dem boden mit schon
jetzt komplett stabilitäts erfährt
gewinn
[Musik]
außerdem habt danke auf jeden fall noch
mal rein und steht dafür dass sie mir
die höhen zugeschickt haben dass wir
hier ein cooles video machen durften und
einfach für die mega keine kooperation
falls ihr bock auf der hülle hat dann
könnte mit diesem code hier mit dem
court luca kriegt 20 prozent auf eure
bestellung bei ihr entsteht in den
nächsten zwei wochen also wenn ihr bock
auf seine hülle hat ihr ein fünftel des
preises mit meinem co die haben wir
nicht nur iphone 10 hüllen sondern auch
noch für andere handys und auch noch für
apple bot schreibt habe ich gerade auch
bei breite geguckt und aber auch papiere
laszlo botka wir nun ein kurzer
vorgeschmack auf eine der nächsten
podcast folgen
[Musik]
also ideal weil der russe und kocht also
wenn du das
sandra sticht auf
wer weiß gerade podcast folge
aufgenommen und wenn man sich damals an
danach anguckt alter die gilt hier
einfach um mit meinen adiletten und
fritz sich hier chocobos kinder bueno
und hat jetzt hier anderthalb kohl schon
leer und festhaltens mit carola wir
jetzt auf jeden fall noch eine folge
potthast auf und dann checkt sandra auch
schon wieder ab
ich muss jetzt bei uns hätte dass ich
auch nicht sandras wechsel slater
ich bin so müde man mag das glaube ich
wirklich nicht glauben wenn man das noch
nie so richtig gemacht hat aber ich habe
heute zwei folgen podcast aufgenommen 45
minuten
wir haben zwei videos aufgenommen die
video aufgenommen haben also einen
stunden an zwei challenges und wir haben
noch den ganzen tag geblockt jetzt und
ich bin ganz ehrlich das ist das ist
jetzt nicht körperliche arbeit aber das
macht ein
das macht einen auch irgendwie echt
chaos
an der stelle wo ich den heutigen blog
jetzt allerdings auch beendet sondern
lieben freunde es tut mir leid dass ich
jetzt hier so komplett müde bin und
nicht mehr viel gefühl und habe seitdem
sonder weg ist aber ich bin komplett
geschafft hat der blog heute gefallen
ich hoffe euch hat die binalshib auch
gefallen ich fand es auf jeden fall mega
cool weil die mir einfach alle
freiheiten gelassen haben einfach so
total locker gesagt hier sind die hüllen
macht irgendeinen schwachsinn damit das
habe ja falls euch das heutige video
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich auf
jeden fall sehr darüber einen daumen
hoch von euch hier unter dem video
freuen und schreibt mir witze gerne wahr
und in die kommentare
ob ich mehr solche blogs machen soll
weil wenn ich locker sehe ich herkomm
mega gut bei euch an
aber ich fühle mich irgendwie schlecht
dabei weil ich weiß ich bin dem ist
jetzt halt nicht übel interessant ich
wirklich da auf jeden fall über euer
feedback freuen und in den kommentaren
abonniert main kanal falls doch keiner
der lupus alle infos 30 14 und in der
beschreibung verlinkt und jetzt könnt
ihr gerne auch sporty vergehen euch neue
folge unseres podcasts anhören dick und
doof ist soeben online gegangen und ich
jetzt
[Musik]
ist in vechta